[موسيقى]
لم تكن صدفه عابره بل كان حبا شغل بال ولي
العهد الاردني نظره فاعجاب وتفاصيل قصه حب
رواها الامير الحسين بن عبد الله
في المدرسه صاحبه رجوى
تعرفت على رجوى من خلالها يعني وكان في
يوم هيك اشي ذكرني فيها قررت اسال عنها
سبحان الله صار نصيب وبتلك الابتسامه ردت
عليه عروسه رجوى حكايه حب ملكيه سيودع بها
الحسين ايام العزوبيه
[موسيقى]
يا ابن عبد الله الثاني
كلمات اختزلت اجمل المشاعر واصدقها الملك
عبد الله الثاني وبخطاب من قلب اب كان
الوطن حاضرا فيه واهم من ذلك هديه لن
ينساها ابنه الحسين
واليوم
كلي فخر فيه فخور
بالحسين بعزيمته بطموحه الكبير لبلد
[موسيقى]
هي الام بمشاعر تلامس القلب كلمات اختصرت
بها الملكه رانيا فرحتها بابنها وعروسها
رجوه التي تلقتها بدموع الفرح رجوى هي
احلى رجاء مني لرب العالمين لحسين
[موسيقى]
وبليله سمر اردنيه بين اصحابه وزملائه من
حمله السلاح تمنى لهم الامير الحسين ذات
الفرح انا كثير انبسطت اليوم
وعقبال كل العزبيه اللي معنا اليوم وكاي
عرس اردني بعاداته وتقاليده هي اعراس بني
هاشم فمن حن العروس الى ليله سمر اردنيه
وكما جرت العاده شباب من العائله
والاصدقاء اتموا حمام العريس
[تصفيق]
وهنا ما يعرف بالقراءه عشاء لابناء الاردن
دعا اليه ابو الحسين الملك عبد الله في
مضارب بني هاشم عين ترقب قصر زهران الذي
سيشهد عقد قران ولي العهد الامير الحسين
على الانسه رجوى وخروج الموكب الاحمر حيث
سيطل عروس البلاد وعيون اخرى ترقب هذا
الحفل الاردني وتزفه بفرح ودعاء وحب لصباح
العربيه عماد العضايله من امام قصر زهران
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات